THE SENATE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER FIVE ON CORRECTIONS,
PUBLIC SAFETY. JUDICIARY. LABOR
AND TRANSPORTATION WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITOL. I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE BE
PRESENT IN ROOM 112 SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND BEGIN OUR
HEARING. TODAY IS OUR FINAL
SUBCOMMITTEE. FIVE HEARING FOR
2024. FOR TODAY'S HEARING, ALL
ITEMS ARE VOTE ONLY. WE WILL
BEGIN WITH PUBLIC COMMENTS ON
THESE ISSUES AND THEN MOVE TO
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR. THE
ACTIONS WE WILL BE TAKING TODAY
REPRESENT THE LEGISLATURE'S
BUDGET PLAN. THESE ISSUES HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSED IN SEVERAL
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS OVER THE
PAST FEW MONTHS. WE HAVE HEARD
AND APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK FROM
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. THIS
IS A TOUGH BUDGET YEAR, MEANING
WE HAVE TO MAKE SOME VERY
DIFFICULT DECISIONS. I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND ASSEMBLY IN A
COLLABORATIVE AND THOUGHTFUL
MANNER AS WE MOVE TOWARDS A
FINAL BUDGET AGREEMENT IN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS. BEFORE WE BEGIN,
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
CONSULTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS WAHAB HERE. DURAZZO
HERE. NEWMAN. SATO THE
CONSULTANT, NOTES A QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED. WE ARE GOING
TO BEGIN WITH PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ALL ISSUES TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS A CHANCE TO BE
HEARD. PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO 30S. AND IF SOMEONE
ELSE HAS ALREADY MADE A SIMILAR
COMMENT, PLEASE JUST ADD A ME
TOO. THANK YOU AND LET'S BEGIN.
AND AGAIN, YOU'RE GOING TO LINE
UP AT THAT MICROPHONE OVER
THERE. GOOD MORNING DANICA.
RADAMEL ON BEHALF OF ROOT AND
REBOUND AND INITIATE JUSTICE, I
WANT TO THANK THE SENATE FOR
REJECTING THE CUTS TO THE ADULT
REENTRY GRANT AND THE THIRD DAY
OF VISITING ON LEVEL FOUR YARDS,
ALSO REALLY URGING THAT THE 12
MILLION LEFTOVER FROM SAN
QUENTIN BE PUT INTO THE RIGHT
GRANT FOR 100 PLUS COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDING
PROGRAMING AND K¾T COR. THANK
YOU. MARIKO YOSHIHARA, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
WORKER POWER, JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THE WORKER EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH FUNDING THROUGH SWAP.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS,
CORY SALZILLO, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION APPRECIATION FOR THE
INCLUSION OF THE $103 MILLION
ONGOING FOR THE VOCA STATE
BACKFILL THAT THE FEDS CUT. WE
APPRECIATE THIS COMMITTEE'S
COMMITMENT AND ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT THAT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. KELLY WALTERS FROM
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN. I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR REJECTING THE
PROPOSAL OF ELIMINATING
VISITATION FOR LEVEL FOR
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS.
MELANIE KIM FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE. THANK YOU FOR REJECTING
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED CUT TO
THE PUBLIC DEFENDER PILOT
PROGRAM. MY OFFICE ALSO SUPPORTS
THE BE THE JURY BUDGET REQUEST
TO RAISE JUROR PAY AND INCREASE
JUROR DIVERSITY. SUPPORTS PRISON
CLOSURES, OPPOSES PROPOSED CUTS
TO VISITING FOR PEOPLE ON LEVEL
FOUR YARDS, AND SUPPORTS
MAINTAINING FUNDING FOR VICTIM
SERVICES PROGRAMS. THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS JASON GOTTLIEB. I'M A
CONCERNED CITIZEN OF CALIFORNIA,
AND I'D LIKE YOU AND URGE YOU.
FIRST OFF, THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. I'D LIKE TO URGE YOU TO
NOT CUT THE VISITATION FOR LEVEL
FOUR INMATES. GOOD MORNING. MARK
WATTS REPRESENTING
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA.
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL TO BACKFILL THE
REDUCTION IN ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM WITH
STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT FUNDING.
THIS HAPPENED LAST YEAR. IT'S
TWO YEARS IN A ROW. IT'S GOING
TO HAVE A CUMULATIVE EFFECT ON
STATE REHAB AND SAFETY PROJECTS.
THANK YOU. NATASHA MINSKER SMART
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA. WE LOVE YOUR
BUDGET PROPOSAL. YOU GUYS ROCK.
YOU DID AMAZING WORK. WE HOPE
YOU WILL MAKE THE PROPOSED CUTS
TO CDCR REAL AND CONCRETE. THANK
YOU FOR EVERYTHING. ELMER
LOZADA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION, WE
WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
FOR HIS DECISION TO CONTINUE
FUNDING THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD FOR HIGH ROAD
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS. WE'VE
SEEN THAT HTTPS HAVE PROVEN THE
SKILL WORKERS AND HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY CREATED PATHWAYS TO
HIGH QUALITY, SUSTAINING
CAREERS. WE WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR CONTINUING TO, HAVE THIS
ACCESS FOR WORKERS. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. JENNY OSHIRO WITH
TRANSFORMATIVE PROGRAMING WORKS
THE RIGHT GRANT 3.0 IS A
NONCOMPETITIVE GRANT VEHICLES
CHAMPIONED BY SENATOR DURAZO
THAT IS EQUITABLY FUNDED MORE
THAN 100 COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT COLLECTIVELY
WORK IN ALL OF CDCR'S PRISONS.
THERE IS $12 MILLION IN UNUSED
FUNDS FROM THE SAN QUENTIN
OUTLAY PROJECT THAT WE'RE ASKING
BE REDIRECTED TOWARDS COMMUNITY
BASED PROGRAMS. PROGRAMS KEEP
OUR COMMUNITY SAFE. THANK YOU.
HELLO EVERYONE. MY NAME IS DOUG
BALDWIN, IMMIGRANT PRISON
PROJECT. I TOO AM IN SUPPORT OF
SUPPORT TRANSFERRING THE
REMAINING 12 MILLION FROM SAN
QUENTIN PROJECTS TO DIRECT TO
THE RIGHT GRANT FOR IN PRISON
CBO PROGRAMING. THANK YOU,
SENATOR DURAZO, FOR THE SUPPORT.
PLEASE PROTECT PROGRAMS THAT
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN PEOPLE'S
LIVES, ENSURING PUBLIC SAFETY
AND WELL-BEING. THANK YOU. I'M
WENDY BANKS, PRISON YOGA AND
MEDITATION. CBO PROVIDED
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS ARE
ESSENTIAL TO CALIFORNIA'S
EFFORTS TO REDUCE INCARCERATION
IN SAFELY AND CBO'S, REDUCE
RECIDIVISM AND PRISON VIOLENCE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR DURAZO, FOR
THE SUPPORT. WE ASK THE THAT THE
ASSEMBLY PROTECT FUNDING FOR THE
WRITE GRANT 3.0 AND REDIRECT THE
12 MILLION FROM THE SAN QUENTIN
OUTLAY PROJECT TO MORE THAN 100
CBOS IN CALIFORNIA PRISONS.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, JOSH
GAGER, ON BEHALF OF THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA, WE APPRECIATE THE
ACTION ON THE SB 678 PROGRAM AND
LOOK FORWARD TO A PARTNERSHIP ON
THAT PROJECT MOVING FORWARD.
WE'RE ALSO EAGER TO PARTNER ON
ANY ONGOING CONVERSATIONS ON THE
JUVENILE GRANT TRANSFER LANGUAGE
OR NEW DATA REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. LASTLY, ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE VENTURA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS, WE
APPRECIATE THE VICTIMS OF CRIME
ACT BACKFILL AND THE REJECTION
OF THE PUBLIC DEFENSE PILOT
PROGRAM REDUCTION. THANKS CHAIR.
SENATORS DEAN GRAFILO ON BEHALF
OF CASE, IT'S THE UNION THAT
REPRESENTS THE THOUSANDS OF
ATTORNEYS, ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGES AND HEARING OFFICERS
ACROSS THE STATE. TWO ITEMS WERE
OPPOSED TO SPECIFIC TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND PROPOSAL.
ITEM ONE IS THE TELEWORK
ELIMINATING THE TELEWORK
STIPENDS. IT'S BEEN NOTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE THAT THE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS RARELY MODIFIED
OR INTERFERED WITH AGREED UPON
LABOR AGREEMENTS. FURTHER, CASE
APPRECIATES THE LEGISLATURE'S
CONCERNS THAT THE PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL WOULD EFFECTIVELY
OVERRIDE SIDE LETTER AGREEMENTS
NEGOTIATED BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION, THÀNH AND THE 17
BARGAINING UNITS. IN PARTICULAR,
BARGAINING UNIT TWO, WHICH IS
THE CASE. MEMBERSHIP ON THE
VACANCY POSITIONS. THANK YOU.
CASE IS OPPOSED TO THAT AS WELL,
TO PERMANENTLY ELIMINATE THE
10,000 POSITIONS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, DAVID
AMAYA FROM ANTI-RECIDIVISM,
COALITION. I AM THE REGIONAL
MANAGER FOR THE HOPE AND
REDEMPTION TEAMS INSIDE
PROGRAMING. I WANT TO THANK YOU
GUYS FOR, PASSING NUMBER 79. AND
THEN ALSO GRATEFUL TO THE FACT
THAT YOU GUYS HAVE REJECTED,
WHAT, 81 THE VISITING, WHICH IS
AN, BIG PART OF OUR REENTRY INTO
SOCIETY AS MYSELF, I SERVED
TIME. I WAS A LIFER AND ALSO 108
THE REDUCTION OF THE REENTRY
GRANT, MAINTAINING THE ADULT
FUNDING TO ALSO VITAL AS THE
SUPPORTS OF OVER 80
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDING
ESSENTIAL REENTRY AND ENCOURAGED
THAT YOU RECOMMEND CONSOLIDATING
AND DEACTIVATING PRISONS TO
ADDRESS STATE'S BUDGET DEFICIT.
SO WE ARE ALL IN AGREEMENT WITH
ITEM NUMBER 80, DEACTIVATING THE
EQUIVALENT OF CAPACITY OF THE
YARDS RATHER THAN INDIVIDUAL
HOUSING UNITS TO SAVE MONEY. WE
DO HOPE THAT CALIFORNIA COULD
WORK TOWARDS CLOSING FIVE OR
MORE PRISONS, WHICH COULD SAVE
OVER $1 BILLION ANNUALLY. FUNDS
THAT COULD BE USED TO SUSTAIN
AND ENHANCE THESE CRUCIAL
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE. MY NAME IS
JAMIL CARTER. I'M WITH THE
ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION AS
WELL. THAT'S MY BOSS. SO I SHARE
VERY MUCH OF THE SENTIMENTS THAT
HE SHARED. BUT I DO WANT TO
PERSONALLY THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING US TO CONTINUE TO WORK,
INSIDE THE PRISON. I'M A PART OF
THE AMAZING HOPE AND REDEMPTION
TEAM WHERE I GO INSIDE THE
PRISON FOUR DAYS A WEEK AND DO
THE WORK INSIDE. WITH THE MEN
AND WOMEN TO HELP THEM COME
HOME. I ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE FUNDS THAT THAT'S
ALLOWING ARC TO CONTINUE TO DO
THE WORK. ONCE THE BROTHERS AND
SISTERS COME HOME RIGHT, SO WE
CAN BE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF SOCIETY
. AND BEFORE I GO, I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU PERSONALLY
BECAUSE I FOUND MY PURPOSE IN
THE WORK THAT I DO TODAY. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING CHAIR.
COMMISSIONERS I'M SEAN GAGE.
PEACE, POWER AND POSITIVITY. Kò,
I'M A MEMBER OF THE HOPE AND
REDEMPTION TEAM AND TÊ
RECIDIVISM COALITION. I WANT TO
PERSONALLY THANK YOU FOR, 79 AND
EVERY POSITION THAT YOU'VE TAKEN
TO HELP REHABILITATE THOSE
INSIDE. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS HOLLY FLEMING. I'M
WITH CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY CENTERS
OF CALIFORNIA, AS WELL AS THE
VOCA ADVOCACY ALLIANCE. WE
WANTED TO ADD OUR DEEPEST
GRATITUDE FOR THE VOCA BACKFILL
FUNDING. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS FLOYD DEE
COLLINS, AND I REPRESENT
AWARENESS INTO DOMESTIC ABUSE. I
AM SIX MONTHS REMOVED FROM
SERVING A 27 YEAR AND ONE MONTH
SENTENCE. I'D LIKE TO SPEAK
ABOUT THE WRITE GRANT 3.0 AND
STATE THAT PEOPLE WHO
PARTICIPATE IN COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION PROGRAMS IN PRISON
RETURN AT A SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER
RATE OF 21, VERSUS THE CDCR
AVERAGE OF 42. WE'RE ASKING THAT
THE REMAINING 12 MILLION FROM
THE SAN QUENTIN PROJECT BE
DIRECTED TO THE RIGHT GRANT FOR
IN-PERSON IN PRISON PROGRAMING
FOR CBOS. WE THANK SENATOR
DURAZO FOR HER CHAMPIONSHIP.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY. MY NAME IS CHÁVEZ RAY
REDMOND, I'M WITH T TP W, WHAT I
WANTED TO SAY WAS COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS IN PRISON
PROGRAMS MAKE REHABILITATION AND
PERSONAL TRANSFORMATION
POSSIBLE, IMPROVE REENTRY
OUTCOMES, MAKE PRISON SAFER, AND
PROVIDE THE STATE WITH
SUBSTANTIAL SHORT AND LONG TERM
SAVINGS. WE THANK SENATOR DURAZO
FOR CHAMPIONING COMMUNITY LED
PROGRAMS. WE'RE ASKING THAT THE
REMAINING 12 MILLION FROM THE
SAN QUENTIN PROJECT BE DIRECTED
TO THE RIGHT GRANT FOR IN
PERSON, COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION PROGRAMS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. GOOD MORNING,
SOPHIA FRANCO WITH THE COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR. AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE JOINT BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO REJECT THE PROPOSED
CUTS TO THE ACT OF
TRANSPORTATION AND COMPETITIVE
TIP PROGRAMS. WE ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BACKFILLING OF ATP
WITH THE STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT
FUNDS. BY REJECTING THESE CUT
CUTS, THEY'RE SAVING MILLIONS OF
LIVES FROM BEING AFFECTED BY AIR
POLLUTION AND CLIMATE CHANGE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE. MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
BOYD. I REPRESENT HONORING
RESILIENCE AND NONPROFIT GEARED
TOWARDS INTERRUPTING THE SCHOOL
TO PRISON PIPELINE PREPARATION
FOR REENTRY SHOULD START THE
FIRST DAY, AND INDIVIDUALS
INCARCERATED THROUGH ENGAGEMENT
IN TRAUMA INFORMED PROGRAMS. CBO
PRISON PROGRAMS ARE DESIGNED TO
PREPARE INCARCERATED
CALIFORNIANS TO RETURN TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES, READY TO LEAVE
CONSTRUCTIVE LIVES. THANK YOU,
SENATOR DURAZO, FOR THE SUPPORT.
PLEASE SUPPORT AND PROTECT
FUNDING FOR THE RIGHT GRANT 3.0
AND REDIRECT THE 12 MILLION FROM
THE SAN QUENTIN OUTLAY PROJECT
TO THESE VITAL PROGRAMS. THANK
YOU. JEANNIE WARD WALLER ON
BEHALF OF CAL BIKE TRANSFORM AND
THE LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY, WE
WANT TO COMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
AND THIS SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
REJECTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED CUTS TO THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM AND
RESTORING, WITH STATE HIGHWAY
ACCOUNT FUNDS, SO HELP TO
ADDRESS THE CRISIS OF FATALITIES
OF PEOPLE WALKING AND BIKING ON
OUR ROADWAYS AND IMPROVE PUBLIC
HEALTH FOR COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
ALCHEMY GRAHAM. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CITY TRANSPORTATION
INITIATIVE, WE'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OUR SINCERE THANKS TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN
PROPOSING TO RESTORE THE 600
MILLION TO THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM THAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY PROPOSED TO BE CUT,
AND WE WILL BE URGING THE
GOVERNOR TO DO THE SAME AND
APPROVE THE PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. THANK YOU, GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS TYSON NGUYEN, AND I'M A
STAFF MEMBER AT THE
ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION. I
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR APPROVAL FOR 79. AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR REJECTION ON 81 AND
108, AND WE HOPE TO GAIN YOUR
SUPPORT ON ITEM 80. THANK YOU.
HOW'S EVERYBODY DOING TODAY? MY
NAME IS DENZEL NONESUCH. I'M A
FORMER JUVENILE LIFER, CURRENT
MEMBER OF ARC'S HOPE AND
REDEMPTION TEAM, AND I AM A LIFE
COACH INSIDE OF NEW FOLSOM
PRISON. AND I CAN TELL YOU
FIRSTHAND THAT THIS WORKS. AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
BRAVE EFFORT TO POUR INTO THESE
MEN TO ENSURE THAT WHEN THEY
COME HOME, THEY ARE READY TO BE
PRODUCTIVE CITIZENS. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS CHRISTOPHER ACOSTA. I'M
A HOPE AND REDEMPTION LIFE COACH
AT VSP VALLEY STATE PRISON. I
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP. I'M ALSO
GRATEFUL TO THE LEGISLATOR FOR
REJECTING THE FOLLOWING ITEMS 81
FOR THE PROPOSED CUTS FOR THE
LEVEL FOR YARD VISITS, 108, FOR
THE REDUCTION AND ADULT ENTRY
GRANT, AND LASTLY, WE AGREE WITH
THE ITEM 80. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, MY NAME IS
LYNN ACOSTA. I AM A HOPE AND
REDEMPTION TEAM LIFE COACH AT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FACILITY IN
CHOWCHILLA. I WORK WITH THE
ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION, I,
WOULD ALSO GRATEFUL FOR THE
REJECTION OF ITEM NUMBER 81 AND
RECOMMEND, THAT WE ARE IN
AGREEMENT WITH ITEM 80.
DEACTIVATE THE CAPACITY OF THE
YARDS. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS VIRGINIA MCDUFFIE.
I'M THE REGIONAL MANAGER OF THE
HOPE AND REDEMPTION TEAM, AND I
WANTED TO SAY A VERY, VERY THANK
YOU HUMBLY. THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORTING ITEM 79. ALSO
GRATEFUL FOR YOU GUYS REJECTING
81 AND 108. AND I ENCOURAGE YOU
TO SUPPORT ITEM 80. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
JOHNNY DIAZ AND I AM A MEMBER OF
THE HOPE AND REDEMPTION TEAM. I
AM A LIFE COACH AT VALLEY STATE
PRISON. I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR APPROVING 79 CONTINUING
THE FUNDING OF THE
ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION. THE
HOPE AND REDEMPTION TEAM, AND AN
IN-PERSON PROGRAM THAT INSTILLS
HOPE AND VALUES. THE EXPERIENCE
OF PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF WHO HAVE
TURNED THEIR LIVES AROUND, WE
ARE ALSO GRATEFUL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE'S REJECTION OF THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS 81 THE PROPOSED
CUTS TO THE THIRD DAY OF
VISITING FOR LEVEL FOR YARD
INMATES AS VISITS ARE KEY TO
SUCCESSFUL REENTRY AND PUBLIC
SAFETY. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
BRANDON PATTERSON AND I AM A
LIFE COACH WITH THE HOPE AND
REDEMPTION TEAM AT JAMESTOWN
STATE PRISON FOR THE
ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION. AND I
JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU GUYS A BIG
THANK YOU FOR APPROVING NUMBER
79. AND I WANT TO SAY WE ARE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
LEGISLATORS REJECTION OF THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS. NUMBER 81 AND
108. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HELLO,
EVERYONE. MY NAME IS JACOB
BREVARD. I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
INSIGHT PROGRAMS FOR THE HOPE
AND REDEMPTION TEAM AND THE
ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION, FIRST
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE WORK THAT YOU GUYS DO AND
INVESTING IN THE COMMUNITY, I
ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
APPROVING 79. AND I AM VERY
GRATEFUL THAT YOU OPPOSED 81 AND
108. AND WE URGE YOU TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF NUMBER 80. AS A
DIRECTOR AT THE ANTI-RECIDIVISM
COALITION, I THINK IT'S VERY,
VERY IMPORTANT TO FUND THE RIGHT
, THE RIGHT GRANT, AND TO
CONTINUE, INSIDE PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WITH
MULTIPLE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND AGAIN, IT'S A REMINDER
THAT IF YOU BELONG TO ONE OF THE
BIG COALITIONS THAT ARE HERE,
PLEASE STATE ME TOO. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS JOSEPH
OSORIO. I'M THE ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR WITH THE
ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION. HERE
IN SACRAMENTO, JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF ARC, ON
BEHALF OF OUR COMMUNITY AND THE
POPULATION THAT WE SERVE INSIDE,
WE KNOW THAT THE FUNDING THAT
YOU ALL PROVIDE FOR US GOES A
LONG WAY AND PROVIDES CRUCIAL
RESOURCES FOR THE POPULATION
THAT WE'RE SERVING. AND THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS COMING BACK
HOME, THANK YOU FOR APPROVING 79
ITEM. AND THANK YOU FOR NOT
SUPPORTING ITEM 81 AND 108. AND
WE STRONGLY, URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
ITEM 80. THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
MORNING, DAX PROCTOR, ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET AND A
CONSTITUENT OF SENATOR DURAZO, I
THANK THIS COMMITTEE FOR
PROPOSING A $500 MILLION CUT TO
CDCR'S BASELINE BUDGET. IT'S A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
HOWEVER, BASELINE CUTS LIKE
THESE ARE CHALLENGING TO
IMPLEMENT BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT
ISN'T BEING TOLD WHERE OR WHAT
TO CUT. WE NEED DETAILED,
ACTIONABLE PLANS FOR THESE CUTS
TO BE EFFECTIVE. IN THE PAST,
CDCR HAS HISTORICALLY
STONEWALLED AND FAILED TO
DELIVER ON PLANS SUCH AS THESE,
EVEN WHEN THEY ARE MANDATED BY
THE FINAL BUDGET. THE LAST THING
WE NEED TO DO IS BALANCE THE
BUDGET ON PAPER ONLY FOR THESE
SAVINGS TO NEVER MATERIALIZE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU CHAIR, COMMITTEE AND
STAFF FOR ALL YOUR TIRELESS WORK
AND THE WORK THAT LIES AHEAD.
RYAN MOORE MOONEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES, FIRST, WE APPRECIATE
THE INCLUSION OF BACKFILL TO THE
VICTIMS OF CRIME ACT, SECOND,
WE'RE INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL FOR
THE CONTINUED REJECTION OF CUTS
TO THE PUBLIC DEFENSE PILOT
PROGRAM. AND THEN WE'RE THANKFUL
FOR OUR REQUEST FOR REPORTING
LANGUAGE FOR THE CALTRANS FLEET
REPLACEMENT HAS BEEN INCLUDED IN
THE AGREEMENT. AND THEN LASTLY,
WE'RE REVIEWING COUNTY IMPACTS
OF THE ASSEMBLY'S PROPOSAL TO
SHIFT THE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM TO THE STATE HIGHWAY
ACCOUNT. THANK YOU, GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR, AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, ESJUAN NUNEZ, ON
BEHALF OF THE ANTI-RECIDIVISM
COALITION, I JUST DITTO WHAT ALL
MY COLLEAGUES SAID AND JUST WANT
TO EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. HOLA,
TODOS. MY NAME IS MARIA
GONZALEZ. SOMOS DE LA SEGURIDAD
PARA TODOS SALAS EL SENADO
INCLUYE A PRESUPUESTO ESTATAL
PARA EL ID INTEGRA INTEGRA UN
PROGRAMA PARA TRABAJADORES
EXCLUIDOS EN LAS ACQUISITIONS
DEL SISTEMA DE ID SIEMPRE ES
POSIBLE. ES MUY IMPORTANTE C¯
ESTA SOLICITUD NO TIENE COSTO
PARA EL PRESUPUESTO ESTATAL
ACTUAL PROPORCIONAR UN BÀN A LOS
TRABAJADORES C¯ CONTRIBUYEN EN
EL ESTADO. GRACIAS I'M JUST
GOING TO TRANSLATE FOR HER. I'M
ALSO PART OF THE SAFETY NET FOR
ALL COALITION, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR MEETING WITH US TODAY, WE
ARE REQUESTING THAT THE SENATE
INCLUDE IT IN ITS STATE BUDGET
PROPOSAL, A REQUIREMENT FOR IT
TO INTEGRATE ELEMENTS OF AN
EXCLUDED WORKER PROGRAM INTO THE
ADX SYSTEM UPGRADES WHEREVER
FEASIBLE. THIS REQUEST COMES AT
NO COST TO THE CURRENT STATE
BUDGET AND WOULD PROVIDE A
PUBLIC GOOD TO WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS WHO ALREADY CONTRIBUTE
TO THE STATE AND TO THE UI. AND
MY NAME IS MARIA AND I'M A
JUSTICE. SAN FRANCISCO. THANK
YOU. HOLA. BUENOS DIAS. MY NAME
IS SARA. CLEAR HERNANDEZ. VENGO
CON LA CON LA. COALITION DEL REY
DE SEGURIDAD PARA TODOS AND CTF
Y APOYO A LA COMPANIA. A
PETITION DE LA COMPANERA PARA
QUÊ NUESTRA INCLUIDA NUESTRO
PROGRAM FOR THE EDD. NEXT,
MUCHAS GRACIAS. HOLA! BUENOS
DIAS A TODOS ME NOMBRE ES KEVIN
TORRES CON ADRIN DE SEGURIDAD
PARA TODOS Y IGUAL ESTOY AQUI
PARA APOYAR A MIS COMPANEROS C¯
LUCIANO PARA ESTÁ ESTA PELEA.
GRACIAS BUENOS DIAS. ME NOMBRE
ES VÀ Y ESTOY AQUI PARA SER ME
TO PARA SAFETY NET FORO DÍAS.
HOLA NGUYEN DE MI NOMBRE ES
DOLLY SANCHEZ. SOY DE LA RED DE
COALITION PARA TODOS Y APOYO EL
ED NEXT. GRACIAS BUENOS DIAS. ME
NOMBRE ES ALONDRA RAMIREZ Y A UN
APOYO A UNA DE SEGURIDAD PARA
TODOS. HOLA. MI NOMBRE ES
MARISOL GONZALEZ. VENGO CON LA
COALITION DE RIVAS PARA TODOS Y
VENGO AND APOYO PARA EL INDEX.
GRACIAS HOLA. BUENOS DIAS, ME
NOMBRA. ROCIO GONZALEZ. TAMBIÉN
ESTOY CON LA COALITION DE
SEGURIDAD PARA TODOS Y TAMBIÉN
ESTOY APOYANDO PARA LA PROPUESTA
AND AGREGADO ED NEXT. THANK YOU.
HI, MY NAME IS KARLA HERNANDEZ
WITH SAFETY NET FOR ALL AND I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS MICHAEL
PIMENTEL HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION,
REPRESENTING 85 TRANSIT AGENCIES
AND STATE, I JUST WANT TO SHOW
THANKS AND APPRECIATION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE'S CONTINUED AND
DECISIVE ACTION TO MAINTAIN THE
$5.1 BILLION PUBLIC TRANSIT
AGENCIES WILL BE ENCOURAGING THE
ADOPTION OF THAT AS THE BUDGET
PROCESS MOVES FORWARD. AND, OF
COURSE, WE'LL BE ELEVATING THAT
TO THE NEWSOM ADMINISTRATION.
THANK YOU AGAIN. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ANDREW ANTWI WITH CHAU
YODER AND TÔI SCHMELZER AND LANG
ON BEHALF OF COUPLE OF AGENCIES,
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY AND ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGIONAL
RAIL AUTHORITY, OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS METROLINK, WE SUPPORT AND
COMMEND THE LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN PUT
TOGETHER, ESPECIALLY FOR THE TIP
FUNDING PROGRAM. WE HAVEN'T HAD
A LOT OF TIME, ON BEHALF OF LA
METRO TO GAUGE THE IMPACT OF THE
ADDITIONAL $500 MILLION
DEFERRAL, I KNOW THERE'S BEEN
SOME QUESTIONS REGARDING THE
SOUTHEAST GATEWAY LINE, BUT NEAR
AS WE CAN TELL, BASED ON A QUICK
CHECK WITH OUR PLANNING AND
GRANTS TEAM, WE HAVE A STRATEGY
TO KEEP THAT PROJECT ONLINE WITH
RESPECT TO DRAWING DOWN FEDERAL
FUNDS. THANK YOU. AND SO WE
SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR MEMBERS JANICE O'MALLEY
WITH AFSCME CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU TO THIS COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
BOLD APPROACH ON CDCR AND
LISTENING TO FRONTLINE WORKERS
IN THE AGENCY PROVIDING THE
MENTAL, MEDICAL AND
REHABILITATIVE CARE BY REJECTING
THE CONTINUED PRIVATIZATION OF
JOBS, WHILE ALSO BALANCING THE
PRESERVATION OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMING. I ALSO WANT TO
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK BY
COMMITTEE STAFF AND LEGISLATORS
TO SUPPORT THE PRESERVATION OF
THE PUBLIC RECORD AND THE WORK
OF OUR COURT REPORTERS AND OTHER
SUPPORT STAFF UNDER THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. LASTLY, WE DO HAVE
CONTINUED CONCERNS ABOUT THE
ELIMINATION OF VACANT POSITIONS,
HOPE TO HAVE CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS ON HOW WE CAN
ENSURE THAT THERE'S TRANSPARENCY
IN THIS DECISION MAKING PROCESS
AND, AGAIN, APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE REJECTING THE
TELEWORK STIPEND. TBL BUT THIS
WAS AN ISSUE THAT WAS
COLLECTIVELY BARGAINED. THANK
YOU. THE ADMINISTRATION SHOULD
RESPECT THAT PROCESS. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS, NICK
BROKAW FROM SACRAMENTO ADVOCATES
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION,
HERE TO JUST EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE AND THANKS FOR YOUR
EFFORTS TO RESTORE, PUSH TO
RESTORE FUNDING FOR THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER PILOT PROGRAM. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HI. MY NAME IS
ROWENA CHIU, I AM HERE, I'M THE
FIRST IN A LONG LINE SEXUAL
ASSAULT SURVIVORS AND ADVOCATES
WHO ARE GOING TO COME UP AND
SPEAK ABOUT FUNDING FOR CRIME
VICTIMS. I WAS AN ASSISTANT TO
HARVEY WEINSTEIN AT THE AGE OF
24. I'M NOW A HIGH PROFILE METOO
ADVOCATE, AND I'M HERE TODAY TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE CONTINUATION OF
FUNDING FOR CRIME VICTIM
SERVICES. I BELIEVE IT'S AN
ESSENTIAL SERVICE, AND I BELIEVE
IT SAVES LIVES. I AM SOMEONE,
TOO, WHO TRIED TO COMMIT SUICIDE
FOLLOWING MY SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
WITHOUT THE FUNDING NECESSARY
FOR ME TO BE IN THERAPY FOR ME
TO SPEAK TO SOMEONE WHO BELIEVED
ME, I WOULD NOT BE ALIVE TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BUENOS
DIAS. ME NOMBRE. VERONICA
LAGUNAS Y SOY DEL CENTRO. ESTÁ
Â PEDIMOS NÓ C¯ PUEDEN HACER EL
PRESUPUESTO DE TRES MILLONES
PARA PODER AYUDAR A TODAS LAS
SOBREVIVIENTES COMO YO DE
VIOLENCIA SEXUAL. BUENOS DIAS.
ME NOMBRE ES ANNABELLA AGUIRRE.
SOY VICTIMA DE LA NOCHE Y
TAMBIÉN PIDO QUÊ PASSING LO
SIENTO THREE MILLONES PARA
AYUDAR PARA LAS SOBREVIVIENTES
CADA ANO. GRACIAS GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS TRICIA MARTINEZ, AND
I'M A SURVIVOR OF MILITARY
SEXUAL ASSAULT. I DID NOT HAVE
AN ADVOCATE, AND IT LED TO A
LONG LINE OF MANY YEARS OF
DIFFICULTY FOR ME. I DON'T EVER
WANT ANYONE TO EVER FEEL THAT
ALONE AGAIN. AND NOW I AM AN
ADVOCATE WITH COMMUNITY BEYOND
VIOLENCE. YOU MUST CONTINUE TO
TRY AND FUND THE VICTIM SERVICES
. THANK YOU. BUENAS TARDES. MY
NAME IS MARTA MEJIA. SOY
SOBREVIVIENTE ACOSO SEXUAL Y LO
SIENTO TRES MILLONES DE RECURSOS
PARA QUÊ NOSOTROS NO QUEREMOS EN
LA CALLE Þ HASTA MÐI RAMOS POR
FALTA DE ESTOS RECURSOS. GRACIAS
BUENOS DIAS. ME NOMBRE ES MARIA
GONZALEZ. SOY SOBREVIVIENTE DE
COSAS SEXUAL DURANGO GIRLS K
FERM POR FAVOR, PARA C¯
VALLAPUDUA LO SIENTO TRES
MILLONES POR LO NECESITAMOS PARA
C¯ NOS DÂN AYUDA PSICOLOGICA E
TAMBIÉN NO SENSACION A DEFENSA.
PERSONAL. MUCHAS GRACIAS. HI, MY
NAME IS ELVIRA HERRERA, AND I'M
HERE AS AN ADVOCATE FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WITH VALORES AND
LIDERES. I AM A SURVIVOR OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. I WAS HELD
HOSTAGE, BEAT, TORTURED AND
RAPED AND SHOT. I WAS LEFT TO
DIE WITHOUT THE SERVICES FOR
VICTIM SERVICES, I WOULD NOT BE
HERE STANDING, ADVOCATING FOR
THE FUNDINGS FOR THIS AGENCIES
THAT HELP ME BE WHO I AM RIGHT
NOW. THANK YOU. HOLA! MY NAME IS
YESENIA ACOSTA. CO-LEADERS.
CAMPESINOS Y SOBREVIVIENTE DE
ASALTO COSAS SEXUAL IN LOS
ANGELES AND LOS CAMPOS Y COMO
CAMPESINOS PARA AQUI PARA PEDIR
C¯ ESOS MILLONES DE DOLARES PARA
C¯ NO SE MAS CAMPESINAS ACUSADOS
POR SU SUPERVISORS Y MAYORDOMO Y
SEGUN LOS FONDOS PARA MAS PARA
QUÊ. ALGUIEN MAS PUEDA SALIR,
ASI COMO YO. MY NAME IS VERONICA
GARCIA. VENGO DEL CAMPESINOS Y
TAMBIÉN VENGO. AQUINO'S DE LO
SIENTO TRES MILLONES Y MAS
PORQUE SOY SOBREVIVIENTE DE
VIOLENCIA DOMÉSTICA PORQUE HAY
MUCHAS KI¾M PERDIDO LA VIDA,
PORQUE NO HAY AYUDAS Y CON ESTA
AYUDA. NOS VA A AYUDAR BASTANTE.
GRACIAS GOOD MORNING CHAIR. MY
NAME IS SARAH DUNBAR RILEY AND
I'M ACTUALLY HERE AS A SEXUAL
ABUSE VICTIM AS WELL AS A PARENT
OF SEXUAL ABUSE FOR MY DAUGHTER.
THESE SERVICES THAT HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED FOR THIS 100.3 MILLION
ARE SO CRITICAL. AS A CHILD, I
WENT THROUGH SEXUAL ABUSE FOR
SEVERAL YEARS UNTIL I FINALLY
CAME OUT WITH IT, AND THIS
AMAZING FUNDING ALLOWED FOR ME
TO REBUILD MY LIFE AND BECOME
SOMEONE WITHOUT GOING DOWN THE
WRONG ROAD, AND THEY HELPED ME
WHEN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WAS GOING
ON. AND THEN JUST TO HAVE MY
DAUGHTER GO THROUGH THE SAME
THING THESE SERVICES ARE
GREATLY, GREATLY NEEDED. AND TO
BE SOMEONE THAT ADVOCATES FOR
OTHER THINGS TO HAVE TO COME
HERE AND ASK FOR THIS, IT'S
REALLY TOUGH BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
USE OUR VOICES WHEN WE JUST
SHOULD HAVE THESE HERE. SO I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND PLEASE MAKE THIS A
PRIORITY, BECAUSE IF IT WAS YOUR
DAUGHTER OR YOUR WIFE THAT HAS
TO GO THROUGH IT, YOU WILL KNOW
HOW IMPORTANT THESE FUNDS ARE.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS ANNE KLEIN. I AM A SURVIVOR
OF CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ABUSE AND
ALSO RAPE. I'M AN ADVOCATE FOR
PARTNERS AGAINST VIOLENCE. AFTER
14 YEARS OF ONGOING THERAPY
THROUGH THEIR SERVICES,
SURVIVORS DEFINITELY ARE
DESPERATELY NEED THESE SERVICES
TO CONTINUE, SO PLEASE, PLEASE
PROVIDE THE 103 MILLION FOR THAT
TO HAPPEN. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS MICHELLE
CATES. I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF PARTNERS AGAINST
VIOLENCE, A RAPE CRISIS CENTER
IN SAN BERNARDINO. I AM ALSO
HERE, ON BEHALF OF MY DAUGHTER,
AS I AM THE MOTHER OF A SURVIVOR
OF CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT. I
AM HERE ASKING FOR THIS $103
MILLION. NOT JUST TO SUPPORT
VICTIM SERVICES, BUT TO SUPPORT
THE LIVES THAT WILL BE SAVED
WITH THIS FUNDING, IT IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL THAT WE
PRIORITIZE THIS $103 MILLION.
THANK YOU. HELLO. MY NAME IS
BONNIE RICE AND I'M THE ADOPTIVE
MOTHER OF A CHILD WHO WAS SEX
TRAFFICKED AS A TODDLER BY HER
BIOLOGICAL PARENTS. AND THIS
$103 MILLION THAT YOU HAVE SO
FAR APPROVED ARE FUND SERVICES
THAT LITERALLY SAVED MY CHILD'S
LIFE AND SAVED MY FAMILY AND
GAVE HER THE OPPORTUNITY TO GROW
UP, TO CHOOSE TO BE THE ADULT
THAT SHE WANTED TO BE, AND I
WOULD ASK ONLY THAT THAT 103 BE
A STARTING POINT AND NOT A
LIMIT, BUT A BOTTOM LEVEL. THAT
IS THE MINIMUM THAT IS NECESSARY
TO SAVE FAMILIES, TO SAVE LIVES
AND TO GIVE EVERYONE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OVERCOME WHAT
HAPPENS TO THEM AS CHILDREN AND
AS ADULTS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR, AND MEMBERS. DAN
SEAMAN, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE, THE REENTRY PROVIDERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION
HERE IN DEEP APPRECIATION OF
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON CRIME
SURVIVOR AND REENTRY ISSUES THIS
YEAR, SPECIFICALLY, PRESERVATION
OF THE FLEXIBLE CASH ASSISTANCE
FOR CRIME SURVIVORS, THE VOCA
BACKFILL SUPPORT FOR THE ADULT
REENTRY GRANT PROGRAM, THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER PILOT PROGRAM,
AND A DEEP APPRECIATION OF
PRESERVATION OF THE HOPE AND
REDEMPTION TEAMS. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS. MICA DOCTOROFF, SENIOR
STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE ACLU OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA, HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION, WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN REJECTING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED CUTS TO THE
PUBLIC DEFENSE PILOT PROGRAM AND
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN HELPING TO
RETAIN THOSE CRITICAL FUNDS. WE
ALSO URGE YOU TO CONTINUE YOUR
LEADERSHIP TO CLOSE CALIFORNIA
PRISONS. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
DIANA, AND I'M A SURVIVOR OF
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ABUSE. AND I'M
ALSO AN ADVOCATE AT SAN
FRANCISCO WOMEN AGAINST RAPE.
AND I'M HERE TO ADVOCATE FOR
FUNDING FOR SURVIVORS. THE
FUNDING CUTS AND WHAT THAT WILL
MEAN FOR SURVIVORS LIKE MYSELF,
WILL HAVE DEVASTATING
CONSEQUENCES FOR SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL ABUSE, EXACERBATING AN
ALREADY CHALLENGING JOURNEY
TOWARDS HEALING AND RECOVERY.
THESE CUTS REDUCE ACCESS TO
ESSENTIAL SUPPORT SERVICES SUCH
AS COUNSELING, ADVOCACY AND
CRISIS HOTLINES, LEAVING
SURVIVORS FEELING ISOLATED AND
UNDERSERVED WITHOUT ADEQUATE
FUNDING. ORGS LIKE MYSELF ARE
DEDICATED TO SUPPORTING
SURVIVORS. MAY IT'S IMPERATIVE
THAT WE RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE
OF SUSTAINING FUNDING FOR THESE
VITAL SERVICES AND ADVOCATE FOR
POLICIES THAT PRIORITIZE THE
WELL-BEING AND EMPOWERMENT OF
SURVIVORS. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS DEBBIE BOYD
AND I AM HERE REPRESENTING MY
DECEASED DAUGHTER WHO LOST HER
LIFE TO VIOLENCE. AND ALSO I'M
HERE WITH THE EMPOWERMENT
RESILIENCE PROJECT, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. AND I JUST ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE SUPPORT
CONTINUED FUNDING, I CAN TELL
YOU, LOSING A DAUGHTER TO MURDER
AND HER BODY HIDDEN FOR 15
YEARS, I, AS A MOM, NEEDED THE
SUPPORT NECESSARY FOR COUNSELING
TO BE ABLE TO INTEGRATE MYSELF
BACK INTO THE WORKPLACE AND BE
ABLE TO THRIVE. AND WITHOUT SOME
OF THE SUPPORT THAT I RECEIVED.
AND I HAD TO LOOK FAR AND WIDE
TO GET IT. IT TOOK A WHILE AND
IF WE DON'T SUPPORT THAT
FUNDING, I AM REALLY A TESTAMENT
TO THE FACT THAT IT DOES IMPACT
THE STATE FINANCIALLY BECAUSE
PEOPLE END UP ON DISABILITY.
THEY END UP, YOU KNOW, IN A
THRIVING JOB. MYSELF AND SILICON
VALLEY, HAVING A BIG TEAM THAT I
MANAGED THRIVING. AND THEN ALL
OF A SUDDEN I COULDN'T DO IT
ANYMORE GOING THROUGH THIS
PROCESS. SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND I'D I'M GOING TO
TRUST THAT WE ALL MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISION TODAY. THANK YOU. HI,
MY NAME IS LYNETTE VANDERSLOOT.
I LOST MY DAUGHTER TO TEEN
DATING VIOLENCE HOMICIDE. I'M
HERE WITH EMPOWER AND RESILIENCE
PROGRAM FROM PLACER COUNTY
VICTIM SERVICE FUNDING IS
CRITICAL TO HELP ENSURE THAT
WHAT HAPPENED TO MY DAUGHTER
DOESN'T HAPPEN TO ANY OTHER
YOUNG WOMAN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TO FUND VICTIM SERVICES
IN OUR STATE. THANK YOU. HI, MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE HERRERA. I'M
HERE WITH THE EMPOWER AND
RESILIENCE PROJECT AND THE
PLACER COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. BUT I TOO AM
UNFORTUNATELY A SURVIVOR OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT. AND WHEN WE HAVE
THESE BUDGET CONVERSATIONS, YOU
KNOW, IN THE SCOPE OF WHAT THE
BUDGET IS, THESE SEEM PRETTY
MINIMAL. BUT I CAN TELL YOU WHAT
THIS MEANS LOCALLY. FOR SOMEONE
LIKE ME, IT MEANS A CRISIS
HOTLINE THAT YOU CAN CALL WHEN
YOU'RE HAVING A DARK NIGHT. IT
MEANS HAVING A PLACE THAT YOU
CAN GO, HAVING GROUPS YOU CAN
VISIT. THESE FUNDS ARE CRITICAL
TO PEOPLE LIKE ME, AND I WORK IN
THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES NOW TO
EMPOWER OTHERS WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED THE SAME THING, AND
THIS BUDGET WILL GO A LONG WAY.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND HOPEFULLY YOUR
SUPPORT. HELLO MY NAME IS ANNA
BERRY AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
CRIME VICTIMS UNITED AND VICTIMS
AND SURVIVORS. PLEASE CONTINUE
THE FUNDING FOR VICTIMS SERVICES
IN CALIFORNIA SO THAT THEY SO
DESPERATELY NEED. WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR ACTIONS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS. TOM
HINCHEY, ON BEHALF OF THE UAW,
WE'RE HERE. IN GRATITUDE FOR
YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT OF THE
HIGH ROAD TRAINING PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM, WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT THE
SENATE IS, FUNDING THAT THIS
YEAR, WE URGE YOU TO KEEP THAT
FUNDING INTACT SO THAT WE CAN
HAVE A VERY WELL TRAINED
WORKFORCE WHO CAN, COMPLETE ALL
OF THE STATE'S CLEAN ENERGY
PROJECTS THAT ARE COMING ONLINE,
AND SO THAT THEY CAN ENTER INTO
GOOD UNION JOBS. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, JOHN SKOGLUND WITH THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES. I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE REJECTION TO THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER PILOT PROGRAM, ALONG
WITH THE REJECTION TO THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FIRE CAMPS, CUTS,
AND WANT TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
BACKFILL FUNDING FOR THE VICTIMS
OF CRIME ACT PROGRAM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING. GLEN
BACCHUS, FOR THE ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS. I WANT
TO COMMEND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
THOUGHTFUL WORK ON THE BUDGET.
WE WOULD RECOMMEND THAT YOU STOP
PAYING FOR EXCESS CAPACITY AT
THE STATE PRISONS IN ORDER TO
PAY FOR VICTIM SERVICES,
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES INSIDE
AND OUTSIDE THE WALLS, AND
INDIGENT DEFENSE. THANK YOU. HI.
GOOD MORNING. MEMBERS. CAROL
GONZALEZ HERE ON BEHALF OF
INCLUSIVE ACTION FOR THE CITY.
VERY THANKFUL FOR YOU ALL FOR
PROTECTING AND REJECTING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO CUT THE
SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL PROGRAM
. SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU, THAT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
CONCLUDED OUR, PUBLIC COMMENTS.
AND HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC, IF THERE
ARE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
SENATOR DURAZO, THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP, ESPECIALLY IN THIS
TIME OF, DIFFICULT, BUDGET, I
WANT TO ALSO THANK THE STAFF
THAT HAVE WORKED SO HARD, TRYING
TO ADDRESS ALL OF OUR CONCERNS,
MY COMMENTS ARE ON, PART B,
ISSUE 15, CALIFORNIA JOBS.
FIRST, THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
FOR THIS ITEM MUST ADDRESS
SECTOR BASED STRATEGIES FOR JOB
QUALITY AND EQUITY, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS GIVEN CLEAR
GUIDANCE THAT FEDERAL
INVESTMENTS ARE MEANT TO IMPACT
JOBS. THE ECONOMY AND POVERTY.
AND THIS INITIATIVE IS MISSING,
THESE ELEMENTS, THIS TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE SHOULD INCLUDE JOB
QUALITY METRICS, IT MUST ALSO BE
A MECHANISM FOR MONITORING AND
ENFORCING THESE STANDARDS. THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE SHOULD
ALSO INCORPORATE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD, WHO HAVE
RAISED CONCERNS WITH THE LACK OF
METRICS, THE SCOPE OF
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC FLEETS IS
HUGE. TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
VEHICLES ARE OWNED AND OPERATED
BY CALIFORNIA PUBLIC AGENCIES,
ACCORDING TO FLEET REPORT, OF
ALL VEHICLES REPORTED TO BE IN
USE, IN A SEVEN YEAR PERIOD, 142
STATE DEPARTMENTS HAVE A TOTAL
OF 46,000 VEHICLES. WHAT WE ARE
VOTING ON TODAY ARE NOT ENOUGH
TO ENSURE THAT THESE NEW, ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE FLEET VEHICLES
ARE MADE BY WORKERS TO RECEIVE
FAIR WAGES AND BENEFITS. IN
FACT, SOME OF THOSE COMPANIES
HAVE FOUND TO VIOLATE WORKERS
RIGHTS. OUR BUDGET SHOULD BE
USED TO CREATE THE MOST PUBLIC
GOOD, NOT REWARD COMPANIES THAT
HAVE SHOWN TO VIOLATE LABOR
STANDARDS. THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR THIS ITEM SHOULD
INCLUDE ADOPTING A BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT FRAMEWORK FOR FLEET
PURCHASES AND WHICH TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT JOB CREATION AND WORK,
PAY AND BENEFITS, ON THE SECOND
ITEM IS PART C, ISSUE ONE ON
GRADE SEPARATIONS. I FEEL WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT PROJECTS IN
EXISTING FUNDING PROGRAMS
RECEIVE THIS FUNDING. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MITIGATE THE IMPACT
OF THESE FUNDS BEING LOST ON
GRADE SEPARATION PROJECTS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN ISSUED A
NOTICE TO PROCEED. IF THIS
HAPPENS, IT WILL MEAN THESE
LOCAL PROJECTS NOT ONLY LOSE
ALREADY ALLOCATED FUNDING, BUT
ALSO HAVE TO RETURN MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. AND USING AS ONE
EXAMPLE OF MANY, THE TURNBULL
CANYON ROAD GRADE SEPARATION
PROJECT. WITH THAT, I THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU, SO I
JUST WANT TO STATE A COUPLE
THINGS. ONE, I REALLY WANT TO
APPRECIATE THE PUBLIC FOR THEIR
INPUT, I THINK THAT IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. OBVIOUSLY,
IT'S VERY CONVOLUTED. YOU KNOW,
WE HAVE ONE DRAFT IN JANUARY AND
THEN, YOU KNOW, WE TRY TO ASSESS
WHAT WE CAN IN THE JANUARY
BUDGET. AND THEN OF COURSE, THE
MAY REVISE WITH VERY LIMITED
TIME TO REALLY LIKE REALLY GET
INTO THE DETAILS. BUT THE
ADVOCATES, THE STAKEHOLDERS, THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND
AGENCIES AND ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAVE COME FORWARD, I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE ALL THE INPUT YOU
GUYS HAVE HAD, IT'S INCREDIBLY
VITAL TO, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE WHO
ARE TAKING A LOOK AT THE BUDGET,
TO REALLY DO THE WORK, I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE LAO FOR REALLY
BEING THERE FOR US, AS WELL AS
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
STAFF THAT COME HERE AND TRY TO
ANSWER OUR QUESTIONS AND SO
FORTH, AS WELL AS EVERY AGENCY
THAT HAS PRESENTED IN FRONT OF
US A SPECIFICALLY WANT TO THANK
THIS STAFF, FOR JUST THEIR
PATIENCE AND A LOT OF THE HARD
WORK AND TRYING TO REALLY LISTEN
TO EACH ONE OF THE ELECTED
MEMBERS NEEDS, AS WELL AS
COMMUNITY NEEDS AND TRYING TO
FIND A BALANCING ACT, I DO JUST
WANT TO SAY, AS CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE, IT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AND I HOPE THAT YOU
GUYS HAVE ALL SEEN THAT WE ARE
VERY MUCH STRIVING TO PROTECT
SAFETY NETS. FIRST, SO A LOT OF
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS THAT CAME
THROUGH REGARDING VOCA FUNDING
AS WELL AS YOU KNOW, THE JOB
TRAINING PROGRAM AND MUCH MORE,
IT IS OUR DEEPEST INTENT TO
PROTECT THOSE. RIGHT. AND I
THINK THAT YOU GUYS HAVE SEEN IN
OUR, RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE ARE
VERY MUCH FOCUSED ON THAT, I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT ALL HAVE THEIR OWN
PASSION PROJECTS AND INTERESTS,
BUT ALSO HAVE LISTENED TO THE
AREAS OF CONCERN FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION, FROM THE
AGENCIES AND MUCH MORE. AND
AGAIN, WHEN WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
FUNDING, ESPECIALLY DURING AN
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN, IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO MAKE DECISIONS. IT
YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT ABOUT
FUNDING, IT'S ABOUT CUTTING
FUNDS. RIGHT. AND THAT'S THE
HARD PART, SO ENTERING IN THIS
POSITION FOR ME FOR THE VERY
FIRST TIME HAS BEEN EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT, BUT BUT AT THE SAME
TIME, I THINK THAT I'M VERY
PROUD OF THIS PARTICULAR BUDGET
PACKAGE THAT WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD. WE HAVE WORKED VERY,
VERY HARD. AND ACROSS ALL THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEES BECAUSE WE
ARE TRYING TO PRIORITIZE THOSE
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS, THOSE
SOCIAL SERVICES, FIRST AND
FOREMOST, REGARDLESS OF THE
COMMUNITY THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
SERVE. SO I REALLY WANT TO SAY
THAT, AS A WHOLE, THANK YOU FOR
BEING PART OF THIS PROCESS, WE
ARE GOING TO BE VOTING ON WE
HAVE OUR SENATOR WHO IS ABSENT
FOR THIS PARTICULAR MEETING, BUT
WE WILL BE VOTING ON ALL ISSUES
FROM PARTS A ONE THROUGH 119,
PART B, ONE THROUGH 41, AND PART
C ONE THROUGH 20, IN ONE MOTION.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION TO ADOPT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THESE
ISSUES MOVED BY SENATOR NEWMAN?
AND AGAIN, I WANT TO THANK THE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US. AND
IF WE CAN HAVE A ROLL CALL VOTE,
PLEASE. SENATORS WAHAB. AYE,
WAHAB. AYE. DURAZO. DURAZO. AYE.
NEWMAN NEWMAN. AYE. SATO THANK
YOU. THOSE ITEMS ARE OUT. 3 TO
0. AND AGAIN, I JUST WANT TO
THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY AS WELL AS THE PAST,
PREVIOUS MONTHS. IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY, PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE TO VISIT OUR WEBSITE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE DO WANT
TO INCLUDE IT. I HOPE THAT YOU
GUYS HAVE SEEN THAT YOUR
COMMENTS AND YOUR INPUT HAS MADE
A DIFFERENCE, AND WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDAS FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. THE SENATE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE, NUMBER FIVE
ON CORRECTIONS, PUBLIC SAFETY,
JUDICIARY, LABOR AND
TRANSPORTATION IS ADJOURNED.